is Bobby Fortis underrated Corner three
badge on the line so Champions are made
[Music]
welcome to underrated the only show that
improves your favorite professional
athletes video game ratings and today A
World Champ Bobby Portis it's time we
get his 2K ratings way up
[Music]
when when Drew drives a lane or Giannis
kicks it out there is something about
you knocking down the three that always
feels like a backboard yeah what is it
like to take the soul of another team I
mean um just playing with great players
makes you uh you know play better as
well just being around those guys made
me change on and off the court but like
you said when those guys kicked the ball
to me as soon as I'm opening the corner
and somebody's flying like a fly by and
look behind him I mean that was a good I
mean those times Yeah dance a little bit
yeah yeah that's that's my thing well
that was the rating that I wanna I wanna
fix today is I want it that even if
somebody's closing in on you it doesn't
impact you nah I got the guy here that
can do it oh yes sir so let's bring him
out hey yo Ronnie
foreign
always a pleasure yes sir I need you to
explain this to me if he's there and
he's shooting and there's a guy coming
at him is there a badge that means
you're really great at this because I
think he's phenomenal yeah well I mean
there's two things first of all catch
and release which I know he's really
good at yep but the badge that we're
talking about is Dead Eye make sure to
hit the shots when uh the defense is
collapsing on someone if that badge is
good you can shoot it right in the eye
of your opponent and so what what is
he's gold in that right now is he silver
I hate to break this to him he actually
does not have a badge at all
really yeah not even a bronze bra not
even a bronze wow that's what the show
is about right yeah I'm here so you're
telling me he can get one today uh
perhaps that's he's gonna have to show
me
[Music]
all right Bobby here's how it works we
got five spots
ten shots gotta hit seven out of ten
okay and as soon as you catch the ball
they're throwing one of these monster
balls at you okay
don't worry about it all right cause
you're a dead eye yes there is you're
getting a badge let's do it he's getting
a bag let's find out three two one go
bang there it is all right we're one of
the one okay
[Music]
two and two start on the makeover all
right we're now at least feeling it the
confidence is in elbow shot catch ball
bang unfazed three of three fourth one
foreign
floater how's your floater game oh yeah
yeah you got it you gotta pump for the
defender when he flying by get to you
how are you gonna pump fake them I don't
know
I can't wait to see it
all right four of five second floater
now we're in
Bobby poured us five of six
see the anger in his face right now oh
all right you're on fire
six of eight just one of two Bobby one
of what we're gonna do is we're adding
an extra Defender
was one oh my god oh closeout so two
shots you gotta hit one bronze badge on
the line how you feeling feeling great
he's feeling great I thought this was
gonna be easy
here it is
oh
and so it all comes down to this
he's holding his follow through yeah
there's a lot on the line though how you
feel uh I mean this is his game he's got
he can prove it to me right here a big
shot
it all comes down to this corner three
badge on the line whenever you're ready
so Champions are made
thank you
foreign
and a little gritty for the kids at home
unbelievable do you feel comfortable
right now
let's give this man the bronze patch
because I know you got pulled yeah well
I will say I was surprised they didn't
have a bronze badge to begin with so
like it's one of those things he he came
out he showed up but I gotta talk to the
team we're gonna have to see what
happens
was he underrated so I can put on the
bottom of the screen right now he ended
up getting the bronze badge yes okay
okay do you feel good about that
absolutely man I appreciate that baby
support us what's up man we're gonna get
him a gold badge
all right so we need to see since Bob
since Bobby did it and these balls they
you know they look like a toy we need to
see how difficult it is okay if he makes
it we'll see him oh my hold on hold on
[Music]
okay I'm ready three two one
I don't know oh that's pretty nice
though it is hard it is hard you can't
even see it
foreign
[Music]